哎真的心灵开嗓
全场跪一会
飞燕赵金薇
仅此一把
目前周边吗还在考虑对
仅此一把需要敲完
需要敲碗
夏天到了
真的到了
不知现在到7月几号
7月中了
热乎乎的夏天
在西安不是四大火炉
那四大火炉更是车流
哎
救救大吉
今天把同事们都带来了对
但是其实想来看同事真的很多
如果本来是就是那个门票允许的话
我们有更多人都想来看看
因为听说北宜昌这这个是我们的一个序幕
休息开始以后
然后开这个座位是整个是往前移动
一共移动距离大概在200米啊
这个目前是全亚洲最大的盛开哇
A few moments later
好棒哦
太厉害了
大家这个已经看得出来
就是有非常非常多的很专注的排练
才可以有这样子很棒的
这个额整体的效果其实是很整体的
这种是集美啊
灯光啊
吸管啊
里面就这是150位
这个我知道你很厉害哦
很厉害哦
大家都是整体小
难怪舅舅大秦会这么火热
大家会来到西安
都会想要看你的眼睛
潮湿的夜人微光温暖着回应哈哈哈
纯属静静等待我的爱
在潮水晶理解的意义不断的嗯
有只为自己的一小心的调温情擦眼
想听的表情
他只想让他们觉得
但是娇哥在这没用
哈哈哈哈哈啊哈哈
这叫烫枕定做的哟
这个还2.0
为什么会是这个呢
因为我很喜欢吃这个巧克力
大家大家的房间
那个这个后台的房间应该都有这个巧克力
所以舒克还有点零
很甜
痛枕痛即痛医之后有了痛心
♪ 可爱都有尘埃呀呀不要为爱失去了爱 ♪
♪ 我要为自己灿烂 ♪
♪ 我的心try变换姿态呀 ♪
♪ 我相信爱自有安排 ♪
♪ 我的美优雅盛开 ♪
♪ 欢迎来新的party ♪
♪ Dding ding ding ding ♪
让你伤心
怎么可以
Sing me
see your快递
你要不要go
这样会有飞行的猫
今天阿泽就抱抱他
然之前我们是合伙起来
就是让阿德反应
昨天是他们两个突然加这个
明天还会加戏吗
不要在这里哦
不会诶
所以很临时
对不对对啊
没讲啊
你表现的很好哦
废话哈哈
那时候是主角突然在下面临时说
不带手机还是没用
路遥好啊好啊好啊
不然以后让你们想好了
嘿嘿嘿
♪ 欢迎来cindy party cinity ♪
♪ Cindy ♪
让人伤心
怎么可以
♪ Sing indy ♪
♪ Cindy ♪
♪ 用快递 ♪
♪ 新年新年来安宁 ♪
咿呀咿呀哟咿哎
这还有事
到如今哎
怎么看一下这个肉有没有违约
人家看那影片啦
你看可以剪那个影片吗
我就这样
风头稳定性很强哦
这段时间我一直在飞
一直在努力
但对西安的想念从来没有淡过
上一次我来西安的时候啊
我去了大唐不夜城
昨天晚上呢我去看了JOJO大秦
我就偷偷摸摸的去
尽量很低调的
没有让很多人发现
我觉得西安真的是一个呃
值得一来再来的好地方
谢谢每一位可爱又热情的你们
到最后一排的
♪ 我好喜欢你 ♪
谢谢你们
♪ 谢谢 ♪
希望我们很快再见
♪ 期待再相会 ♪